es geht los es ist das erste mal seit
1972 dass wir wieder zum mond fliegen
und mit dabei wird ein weltraumtourist
sein edel max raumfahrtunternehmen
spacex hat das jetzt angekündigt und
ihnen macht hat auch einen hinweis auf
die identität des ersten mond touristen
gegeben klicks um sind weg schon
herzlich willkommen zu den elenas
chroniken erstens es kommt immer alles
anders und zweitens als man denkt schon
vor geraumer zeit hatte spacex den flug
zum mond angekündigt doch daraus wird
wohl nichts space ex hatte damals den
mondflug mit einer bemannten dragon
-kapsel verkündet das ist die
wiederverwendbare kapsel die bereits
jetzt regelmäßig die internationale
raumstation mit equipment
verbrauchsgütern und nahrung versorgt
die crew dragon wird zum ersten mal
bemannt mit den astronauten robert
behnken und douglas hurley im april 2009
10 zur internationalen raumstation iss
fliegen banken war bisher bei zwei space
shuttle missionen mission spezialist
hurley nahm auch an zwei
shuttle-missionen teil und war pilot des
letzten space shuttle fluges am 8 juli
2011 doch die crew dragon ist jetzt
offenbar für mondflüge erst mal nicht
geplant sondern es geht direkt mit der
bfr der big felken rockend oder wie
maske sie gerne nennt der big fucking
rocket zum und sie zum ersten mal wieder
seit der saturn 5 höher als 100 meter
und damit die größte aktuell
existierende rakete wenn sie dann fertig
gebaut ist aber da ist basics ja extrem
schnell mit der entwicklung gerade wurde
die neue version der völker lion
vorgestellt die völkern heavy ist
erfolgreich gestartet und jetzt geht es
konkret an die bfa und sie kann mit
daten aufweisen die einfach nur
sensationell sind 106 meter ist die
gesamte mit den antriebs stufen 2019
sollen sie fertig entwickelt seien die
bfa ist wieder verwendbar um die kosten
niedrig zu halten
das ist ja sowieso der kasus knaxus von
spacex das unternehmen hat es ja
geschafft raumfahrt deutlich billiger zu
machen
fast alle teile der rakete bis auf die
zweite stufe können wiederverwendet
werden
und das wird auch so bei der bfa seien
hier dürfte sogar die zweite stufe die
offenbar auch während des raumfluges als
antrieb dient wieder einsetzbar sein
mit jedem flug kann die bfa 100 menschen
plus fragt in 40 kabinen fliegen
die bfs sind zusätzlich mit großen
gemeinschafts bereichen frachträumen und
so weiter ausgestattet wenn das jetzt
mit diesem riesigen raumschiff und nur
einen einzigen menschen zum mond fliegen
will lässt dass viele fragen offen was
ist die restliche fragt des raumschiffes
wird der erste tank mit treibstoff für
einen flug zum mars in den erdorbit
gebracht dann denn das ist der plan für
max maas flüge zuerst werden
treibstoffdepots im erdorbit angelegt um
dann dort bfs nach dem start von der
erde wieder mit treibstoff zu befüllen
und dann damit zum mars zu schicken oder
ist der tourist der am montag bekannt
gegeben wird nur der erste von 100
touristen
es wird extrem spannend jedenfalls hat
macht schon einen hinweis auf den
passagier gegeben
gefragt ob er es selbst sein wird hat er
als antwort eine japanische flagge
getwittert es muss also eine superreiche
japanerin oder ein superreicher japaner
sein
wer hat eine idee wie es sein könnte
schreibt es in die kommentare und jetzt
ihr könnt klicks um weiter werbefrei
machen keine priols mehr mit eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal
mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir
die werbung für jeweils einem video im
monat ab das erste video gibt es ja
schon und es werden mehr also pro monat
jeweils monatlich also zwölf videos
haben wir inzwischen werdet also
mitglied hier oder dem video
draufklicken und bekommen noch exklusive
extra videos exklusive live streams und
noch ein paar weitere privilegien einen
riesen dank an all diejenigen die schon
dabei sind wenn er immer garantiert über
aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt
dann endet mich übrigens bei whatsapp
dann bekommt ihr den link zum video vor
allen anderen mit von mir persönlich auf
euer handy einfach hier draufklicken und
da drunter geht's weiter dafür auch
draufklicken mitte mondstation standort
gefunden bis dann bleibt dran